The fire is so delightful
Since we've no place to go
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
It doesn't show signs of stoppin'
And I brought some corn for poppin'
Lights are turned down low
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
When we finally kiss goodnight
How I'll hate goin' out in the storm
But if you'll really hold me tight
All the way home I'll be warm
The fire is slowly dyin'
And, my dear, we're still goodbyin'
As long as you love me so
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
He doesn't care if it's ten below
He's hittin' by the fire's cozy glow
He don't care about the cold and the winds that blow
He just says, let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
When we go to start
Why should he worry when he's nice and warm
He's gelled by his side and the lights turn low
He just says, let it snow, let it snow
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
He doesn't show signs of stoppin'
And I brought lots of corn for poppin'
The lights are way down low
So let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
When we finally say goodnight
How I'll hate goin' out of the storm
But if you'll only hold me
Let it snow, let it snow
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
When we finally say goodnight
How I'll hate goin' out of the storm
But if you'll only hold me
Let it snow, let it snow
When we finally say goodnight
How I'll hate goin' out of the storm
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow
Let it snow, let it snow
Slaybells ring
In the dark
I'm feelin' bad
How I'll hate goin' out of the storm
But if you'll only hold me
Let it snow
When we finally say goodnight
How I'll hate goin' out of the storm
Let it snow, let it snow
When we finally say goodnight
So, zumindest
Ähm
Hier neben kommt dann, das habt ihr schon im Stream gesehen, kommt das Netzteil rein
Dann hab ich's jetzt so gemacht, dass der rot, der blinkt rot, bis er WLAN Zugang gefunden hat
Also ja, meine ähm
Meine Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung hat WLAN
So und Standardmodus ist dieses Kerzen Ding, was wir ja schon teilweise im Stream aussehen
Was wir ja schon teilweise im Stream ausprobiert haben, was ich aber dann zum größten Teil auf Stream gebastelt hab
Ähm
So und jetzt kommt das, was ich komplett auf Stream gemacht habe
Ich hab so ne Webseite noch eingebaut
Wenn es, warte mal, mal gucken
Irgendwann, hier stellt es sich kurz scharf
Ich hab so ne billige Webseite noch auf dem Controller eingebaut, wo man auswählen kann
Ähm, Kerzenmodus hell oder bunt oder heller und dunkler
Es läuft alles auf dem ESP32 hier, der in dieser, der in der Box drinne ist
Das ist der RGB Weihnachtsbaum
Hier
Pass mal auf
Wenn du mir das nicht glaubst, dass das RGB ist und für dich so klassisch aussieht
Hier, sagst du dazu
RGB Weihnachtsbaum
Ja
RGB Weihnachtsbaum und wie gesagt mit Webinterface-Steuerung
Und wenn es zu dunkel ist, kann man auch komplett, doch, klar, RGB
Das sind
Das ist, das ist, ja
WS2811
Strip
Was? String, meinetwegen
Ja, das hier
Sowas in der Richtung ist das hier
50 LEDs
Und das Coole ist, dass das tatsächlich
Echt, ähm
Ganz gut, ganz gut vom Kabel her passt, weil das Kabel ist schwarz und ähm
Die
Die Mini-Controller in den LEDs sind grün
Und passt richtig gut in den Baum rein
Mein Bild ist ganz schön shab, oder?
Guck mal
Okay, ich halte das Handy auch shab
Man sieht es hier unten an dem Tisch, ja
Aber trotzdem, also
Ich glaube das ganze Bild könnte man mal ein bisschen weiter rechts
Rücken
Ja, das ist aus dem
Übrigens die Katze hat das mit Geschenke verpackt
Das, man muss ja eins
Eins muss man dem
Äh, iPhone XR
Mal zugute halten
Die
Wie kann man jetzt hier das Bild in groß machen?
Früher hatte Twitter
So einen
So einen Button oben dafür, wo man das Bild groß machen konnte
So
Eins muss man sagen, das iPhone XR
Macht, macht für, für einfach mal so
Random
Auf Foto gezwitscht und gedrückt
Macht es ziemlich gute Fotos, ne?
Ich mein, du kannst da hier
Im Prinzip
Du erkennst hier sogar die einzelnen Haaren und so vorne
Für einfach mal
iPhone aus der Tasche geholt und drauf
Ge, ge
Fotografiert, die sehen die Fotos so echt gut aus
Ich mein, das kann man natürlich nicht vergleichen
Mit einer ordentlichen Kamera
Beziehungsweise jemand, der das kann
Aber spiegel ich mich
Spiegel ich mich?
Chico, zeig mal
Eindeutig
Revealed
Ich seh mich hier ganz genau
Leaked
Das ist genauso wie
Max in der Peking-Suppe von 2013
Ja
Eindeutig, da wurd ich auch geleaked
Übrigens, habt ihr das schon mitgekriegt?
Ich glaub, das hat mir sogar einer letztens im Stream erzählt
Da musste ich mir echt wieder
An den Kopf greifen, ey
Habt ihr, habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Alter, also
Es ist, es ist so bescheuert mal wieder
Wo ich mich wieder denke, Leute
Es ist das, ist das
Also es ist so bescheuert
Dass man es nicht ernst nehmen kann
Aber es ist ernst
Genommen worden
Und zwar, oh, ich hab was mit dem
The real Syntax, Twitch Prime
Dankeschön
Alles Dankeschön, Pog
Ok, ich hab nix übersehen
Zumindest, es hat bei
Was, nur ein 720p?
Nee
Das liegt an dir
Bei mir ist es 1008p, Sebaro
Oder, oder ist der
Angesagt
Refresh, Refresh, Sebaro
Das ist 1080p
Naja, zumindest, also
Ich glaub, es hat sogar jemand
Im Stream geschrieben letztens, ob ich das kenne
Und ich konnte es nicht zuordnen
Wenn ich nutze, die App, was in der App
Ich geh jetzt mal in meine App
Vielleicht ist meine, vielleicht sind meine
48 FPS zu excellent
Für die Twitch App
Ich muss jetzt mal in die App gucken, ob ich auch
Ob ich
Auch nur 720p habe
Nö
1080 in der App
Sebaro da, stimmt fast nicht
Ja, nö
Funktioniert
So
Also
Man hält es für Satire
Ich glaube, es ist ein Trollversuch
Wie Microsoft da drauf
Reagiert hat, ist auf den
Ersten Blick, finde ich, erschreckend
Auf den zweiten Blick haben sie es aber echt clever gemacht
Leider hat es keiner
Hat es keiner mehr mitbekommen
Der Typ
Visual Studio Code, also das ist ja
Der Editor von Microsoft
Also eigentlich eines
Eines der größten und beliebtesten
Projekte auf GitHub
Die haben
Zu Weihnachten eingefügt
Dass man
Dass man hier unten
Neben dem Settings Icon
Einen
Weihnachtsmann Hut hat
Einen Santa hat
Wo man jetzt ja eigentlich von ausgehen würde
Wer um alles
In der Welt kann sich an so was
Stören
Man hält es nicht für möglich
Dass sich Leute da dran stören
Doch, dennoch
Hat sich da jemand dran
Gestört
Und
Ich halte es ja nach wie vor für einen Troll
Ja
VLC
VLC hat auch
Genug Threads dazu
Und der Autor von VLC macht das
Meiner Meinung nach richtig
Der sagt, forke den Player oder verwende ihn nicht
Naja, zumindest
Hat der Typ sich hier wahnsinnig
Darüber aufgeregt
Wie offensiv der das findet
Weil ja im Namen
Irgendwie im christlichen Namen
So viele Juden verfolgt wurden
Und hier hat er irgendwie den Blogpost
Verlinkt, was irgendwie was mit
Diesen Blogpost
Guckt ihn euch gar nicht an, da sind teilweise
Dinger drin, wo ich mich so denke
Irgendwelche satanischen
Sachen Bezug genommen, wo ich mir denke
Alter, was ist mit den Leuten los, ja
So, ähm
Danach ist die Frage ob, genau
Danach ist eh die Frage, inwieweit der Weihnacht
Wann jetzt für christlichen Fanatismus steht
Ich weiß ja
Nicht so genau, aber gut, zumindest
Dieses Issue hat der Typ aufgemacht
Wie gesagt, guckt euch gar nicht an
Zumindest
Das lustige ist
Daran, es gibt übrigens
Mittlerweile zigtausend Leute, die sich
Offended sind gegen alles mögliche, die machen
Jetzt hier Issues auf bei Microsoft
Zumindest, er hat es hier nochmal
Gepostet, so nach dem Motto, ja
Passt da unten um dieses Alten geht's mir
Und er ist halt, es ist auch
Es ist auch erstmal vollkommen egal, ob es
Gerechtfertigt oder nicht, und gehen wir mal
Davon aus, er ist kein Troll
Meiner Ansicht nach ist er einer, aber wollen wir mal
Davon ausgehen, dass er keiner ist
Dann, ähm
Eluminato, Twitch Prime, drei Monate vor Weihnachten
Dankeschön, wünscht ihr auch
Big Brain
Und gehen wir einfach mal davon aus, es stimmt
Dann ist es ein gutes Recht
Darüber
Offended zu sein, sich angegriffen zu fühlen
Kann er machen, ist okay
Dann zu fordern, dass bei einem
Sagen wir mal so, dass
90.000 eines der größten
Softwareprojekte
Fast schon die es so öffentlich gibt
Dass man dann als Einzelperson
Fordert, weil man
Persönlich sich
Angegriffen fühlt, dass es für alle
Entfernt werden soll, halte ich schon
Für fragwürdig
Das ist ein bisschen so
Ähm, bevor wir zu, wir kommen gleich
Zur Antwort von Microsoft, ich finde das ist
Ein bisschen so, mal angenommen ihr wohnt
Neben einer Kirche
Kommt ja vor, ihr wisst
Ich habe früher in Ulm gearbeitet
In Ulm gibt es so einen Dom, oder ne
Wie heißt das Ding da? Münster
Und so eine Kirche
Gibt es in Ulm
Und die billigsten Hotels sind die
Direkt neben
Der Glocke
Die sind diesen billig, der kostet irgendwie 15 Euro die Nacht
Das ist das
Hotelzimmer, wo ich es mal hatte
Dass das Bett neben dem Klo gestanden ist
Da war keine Kabine neben Dusche und Klo
Da war einfach das Bett, Klo
Irgendwie 15 Euro die Nacht
Oder so, ja
Und
Es ist so
Wie wenn man beispielsweise in so einem
Hotelzimmer übernachtet neben dem Ulmer Münster
Oder
Oder wenn man da vielleicht sogar wohnt
Und dann sagt man, okay
Mich fuckt das voll ab
Dass die ganze Zeit diese Glocke klingelt
Es hat mich übelst abgefuckt, als ich da
Übernachtet habe
Ich hatte jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten
Entweder
Ich gehe in ein anderes Hotel
Ich
Lebe damit
Oder ich gehe auf irgendeine Social Media Plattform
Und reg mich wahnsinnig drüber auf, wie scheiße das Ulmer Münster ist
Weil sie eine Glocke hat
Leider habe ich das Gefühl
Dass in der heutigen Zeit
Viele Leute zu drittem tendieren
Dass die sagen, das ist eine Sache, die
Pisst mich persönlich an, deswegen muss ich
Das jetzt der Welt mitteilen und die Welt
Hat sich gefälligt nach mir
Zu richten. So ungefähr, so ein bisschen
Kommt mir das Ganze an der Stelle auch vor
Ich finde es schon
Echt fragwürdig, das überhaupt so was
Aufzumachen. Ich meine, es ist ein Troll, meiner Ansicht nach
Ja
Aber es gibt genug Sachen, die ernst gemeint
Sind in dieser Richtung
So, was ich jetzt
Auf den ersten Blick
Was mich echt bisschen gewurmt hat
Von Microsoft, ist die Antwort
Ich meine, der Typ, der regt sich ja
Über christliche Sachen auf und der Typ hieß
Ihm Namen dann auch Christian Schiffer
Also, das ist 100%
Ein Troll, also 99%
Zumindest
Die Antwort hat mich erstmal so ein bisschen
Gewurmt
Weil ich meine, man kann doch nicht
Wenn sich
Bei solchen Sachen
Wenn einer von irgendwie
Keine Ahnung
Hunderttausenden Benutzern sich an irgendwas
Stört
Kann man doch nicht instant sagen
Jawoll, wir entfernen das
Es gibt doch bestimmt genauso viele Leute
Die sich mit Sicherheit darüber
Freuen, dass es da jetzt ein Santa hat gibt
So, das heißt will man sich jetzt
Wirklich so anmaßen
So nach dem Motto, ist es jetzt wichtiger
Dass sich vielleicht
Viele tausend Leute freuen
Oder ist es wichtiger, dass er sich jetzt
Darüber aufregt
Deswegen hat mich die Antwort von Microsoft
Ein bisschen gewurmt
Warum gehen die denn bitte schon so schnell
Darauf ein und dann auch noch so direkt
Schwanz einziehen
Bis ich mich dann ein bisschen
Wobei die ist so leise, das stört eigentlich
Bis ich mich dann noch ein bisschen damit
Beschäftigt habe
Und wisst ihr mit was Microsoft
Das geht hier überhaupt nicht drüber hervor
Außer dass die Leute sich wahnsinnig
Darüber aufgeregt haben und sie den Thread
Gelöscht haben
Wisst ihr was Microsoft
Stattdessen für einen Icon reingemacht hat
Anstatt dem
Ich weiß gar nicht ob das
In meiner Version drin ist
Eine Option, die Option gibt es glaube ich
Sogar schon, dass man custom Icons
Ausschalten kann
Oder war das nur im Insider
Das kann sein, dass das nur im Insider Bild drin ist
Ich glaube das war nur im Insider Bild
Wisst ihr durch was Microsoft das
Ausgetauscht hat und das fand ich eigentlich
Eine richtig lustige Aktion, durch eine Schneeflocke
Und
Klingt erstmal voll unverfänglich
Aber gerade im
Englischsprachigen Raum
Wird ja das Wort
Snowflake gerne mal für Leute verwendet
Die sich über solche Sachen
Öffentlich laut halt
Empören
Und deswegen fand ich das
Eigentlich schon ganz witzig, dass sie da eine
Schneeflocke reingemacht haben anstatt
Leider hat das
Die ganze Welt hier wieder nicht
Haben die Leute das wieder nicht
Gecheckt und spammen jetzt
Und spammen jetzt
Das Repo
Voll
Mit Sachen wo sie offended sind
Guck, die mussten das Repo closen
Die mussten das Repo closen
Weil zu viele Leute, der eine
Der eine hat ein Issue aufgemacht
So nach dem Motto
Ich bin als Kind mal am Flughafen
Verloren gegangen, das Wort
Terminal offended mich unglaublich
Bitte entfernt das Terminal aus
Visual Studio Codes
Ja gut
So und da sieht man ja auch schon in was für
Eine Lage man sich manövriert bei so was
Weil wie möchte man es jetzt
Wirklich
Schlüsslich begründen
Dass man hier das sofort macht
Und bei dem anderen, unabhängig davon ob er
Troll oder nicht, der quasi Todesängste
Durchstehen muss, jedes Mal wenn er das Wort
Terminal liest
Wie will man das rechtfertigen
Dass der wichtig ist und der andere
Nicht oder der hier nicht und der andere wichtig
Kann man eigentlich nicht
Deswegen sollte man bei solchen Projekten
Einfach den Ball ein bisschen
Flacher halten so was
Dayaxe ist am Start
POG, ja aber nicht lang
Nicht lang, ja
Michael 50 Billiarden
Ich bin aber nicht lange da
Ich bin nur da, bis Essen
Da ist
Über die Android App
Über die Android App kann ich jetzt nicht bauen weil mein Tablet drüben
Ist
Also meine 14 Tablets
Es ist so krass wie sich mittlerweile Tablets
Hier angesammelt haben ohne Ende
Zwei Shield Tablets
Ein Asus Tablet
Zwo
Fire HD 10
Fire HD 8
Ein Tegra Node
Ein iPad
Zwei, drei iPhones
Alter so viel, so viel Geschiss
Wer braucht das eigentlich alles
Da sind wir heute wieder beim Thema
Was man da so kriegt
Weiß nicht
Brauchen tut man es eigentlich nicht
In der Android App geht eine 720p
Das liegt bestimmt an meinem Codec
Könnte ich mir vorstellen weil die Problem
Oder beziehungsweise nicht, das liegt an 48 FPS liegen
Oh guck mal
Oh Gott ich bin offended
Weil Google eine Schneekugel hat
Android ist das Problem
Android hat
Ziemliche Probleme mit Hardware
H264 Decoder
Liegt nicht so sehr an der Android Version
Sondern liegt an der Hardware
Zum Beispiel
Funktionierte
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen
Dass es echt noch ein Ding ist
Bis vor einigen Jahren auf ganz vielen
Android Tablets
Funktionierte
Im Chrome
Auf YouTube der H264 Decoder nicht
Nur die Software
Also nur Software Decoding, keine Hardware Decoding
Da muss man tatsächlich mal sagen
Das ist eine Sache die kriegt Apple seit 10 Jahren hin
Ich meine H264
Ist uralt, hat das 15 Jahre
Codec oder so
Von wann ist denn der
Das ist uralt
Das ist Steinzeit
H264 Codec
Und Android hat es bis vor ein paar Jahren
Auf vielen Geräten nichts geschafft
Videos Hardware zu decoden
Im Browser
Mittlerweile kriegen sie es ganz gut
Gebacken weil die Hersteller auch drauf achten
Da hat es Apple halt leichter
Apple muss halt im Endeffekt
Nur seinen eigenen Crap supporten
H264
Nuke
Am imbalance
Das war's für heute.
Das ist für heute.
dass die die zukunft was massenspeicher angeht also im wissenschaftsumfeld
dass da schon immer mehr in richtung clusterfile also nicht clusterfile
system sondern so distributed storage sowas wie cef oder wie heißt das andere
wie heißt das zweite was noch bekannt ist cef und
lasse also nicht das nicht das war ich meine was jetzt voll angesagt
cluster kennt man das meinte ich nicht irgendwas es gibt doch
irgendwas neues was jetzt voll angesagt ist letztens erst gesehen sind da das
sind da ach keine ahnung adf es kann sein ist er auch egal
muss man kürze meine mails gucken nicht dass die dass die liefertypen der
meinung sind ich war nicht da oder so also mein essen sich anrückt
das nehme ich diesmal anders gemacht
heute mittag haben wir normal gefuttert und für heute abends bestellen
fast sogar bürger bestellt für heute abend aber nicht mcdonalds oder so eine
richtig nice bürger hier vielen dank für deine bestellung
ok die müssen noch die müssen noch gleich kommen
letzte warnung please read now letzte war ja ist klar
den nicht mcdonalds wir haben bei uns einen ziemlich guten bürgerladen
und der auch liefert excellent
das ist big brain hier den den weißen raum auf weißem untergrund zu machen
sieht man sieht man nix was hast du für ein set up was ich weiß nicht was so
was du dich beziehst gerade
fußel tv also ich habe ja hier im stream mal vor einer weile ein bisschen
rum experimentiert ich habe jetzt hier meine kiste zusammengebaut mit 2
terabyte system ssd 14 terabyte hdd für backup geschichten und 10 tera und 10g
pc express karte für wenig geld aber das ist kein bild wo ich großartig
empfehlen würde nachzubauen ehrlich gesagt ist zu zu experimentell
ach pizzerik
aktuell habe ich in 8700 k mit 1080 ti und 16 g ram
16 g ramme ja wobei ich kurz davor war vor einer woche
mir in den reisen 3950 x zu bestellen und dann letzte woche noch mal kurz
davor nicht doch vielleicht im threadripper 3960 x zu bestellen
zock nation fragt ich habe eine frage an dich ich studiere informatik und bin bei
c und c plus plus bei den pointen hängen geblieben auch sehr schönes thema
excellent was ist der nutzen wofür nutzt man das anwendungsbeispiele für
den dümmsten informatikstudenten wirklich wofür man pointer benutzt wenn ich dir
jetzt sage um sich speicher adressen zu merken
bringt er das dann irgendwas
ein pointer ist eine variable wo eine adresse von einem speicher drinstehen
was ein schönes beispiel wofür man ein pointer braucht zum beispiel wenn du
wenn du von einer funktion genau der tommy sagt mal angenommen du hast
irgendwo irgendwo im ram hast du sachen stehen die deine anwendung brauchen es
ist vollkommen egal was ja sachen ist auch egal um welche anwendung keine
ahnung audiodaten also vollkommen wurscht ja irgendwas und irgendwo legst
du das ding an allerdings die stelle wo du das anlegst und befüllst ist ja nicht
unbedingt die stelle wo du es benutzt so und wie bekommst du denn jetzt die
information an welcher stelle im arbeitsspeicher deine daten sind
transportiert an die stelle wo du sie benutzen willst
das geht ja nur mit einem pointer im prinzip ist jede variable ein pointer
es stimmt nicht so ganz ja es kann auch im cash von der cpu und generell so
mal theoretisch also von der idee ist jede variablen pointer weil eine variable
die machen das natürlich schöner sie musste nicht von hand dereferenzieren
und sonst was wenn du jetzt eine variable hast wo eine zahl drinnen
steht dann steht die variablen ja nie da steht die zahl ja nicht in dieser
variablen sondern die zahl steht irgendwo in irgendeinem speicher und die
variablen weiß wo die adresse ist wo die zahl steht die sache da fehlt die
vorstellung für ne tommy das ist jetzt zu viel außerdem ist es im prinzip alles
ram egal ob stack oder hieb alles ram der einzige unterschied ist was die
sachen automatisch quasi weggeschmissen nachdem die funktion zu ende ist und das
eine ich glaube in z das eine unten anfängt das andere oben aber im prinzip
ist beides ramm
ich überlege grad wie könnte man das wir machen jetzt mal wir machen jetzt mal
was es kann aber jederzeit sein dass man essen kommt da sage ich euch gleich
also wir machen jetzt mal vm an man in c++ projekte auf bestes thema für
weihnachten
nehmen müssen wir gar nicht ich habe noch viel bessere idee wir können es ich
kann es in meinem letzten letzten dotnet projekt sogar zeigen das kann ja an
save point da können wir uns noch mal z plus ich habe ich habe ein gutes
beispiel für ich habe ein gutes beispiel wofür man point da braucht
so also
also gerade mal die stelle finden genau das hier also das hier ist eine das
jetzt ein programm was im prinzip videos von wie in video stream von der
webcam liest erst mal egal was es macht an dieser stelle warum habe ich eigentlich
kein kein highlight kann mir das immer jemand erklären
warum habe ich kein highlight ich bräuchte so ein bisschen highlighting und
autocomplete jetzt der net verkehrt akkumpilieren vielleicht
ich habe überhaupt keine dort net versionen installiert na gut habe ich
das habe ich das vielleicht den falschen studio aufgemacht was habe ich
aufgemacht ich habe 17 aufgemacht ich kacke nur oder ich habe 19 aufmachen müssen
oessen ist da leute ich muss mich bei also ich versuche das immer kurz zu
erklären da da muss auf also hier funktioniert es ok also
also so wie gesagt das ist ein projekt was video streams von der kamera liest
und du siehst hier sind ganz viele ganz schon mal ganz viele pointer am start
selbst was sie scharpe aber es ist anzelt sie scharpe das ist im prinzip
syntaktisch so gut wie kein unterschied was pointer angeht zu c++ zu allem
anderen ist ganz schön so guck mal an der stelle hier an der stelle der
servier ich speicher für den packet den packet ist bei ffm pack das encoded
das video daten ist auch egal das hier ist ein pointer und zwar ein pointer zu
einem av packet hier legt er den speicher an und hier merkt er sich die
die die adresse zu dem zu dem speicherbereich so du siehst in dieser
funktion hier verwende ich nirgendwo oder mache ich nichts mit diesem packet
in der ganzen funktion passiert direkt mit diesem packet nix das einzige was ich
mache ich gucke ob das in den video stream ist ob ich das weiter lesen will
aber ansonsten ich lese hier einmal ich lese hier einmal den input rein
ich wurde gerade auch darauf hingewiesen dass das essen da ist
das einzige wo ich war es in der funktion mache ist das hier und die
eigentliche arbeit passiert zum beispiel in in dieser funktion hier wird ein
thumbnail genommen in meinem oder die tür aufgemacht
hier wird ein thumbnail aus dem video stream extra hier die sache ist jetzt
plus die wie kriege ich denn die information hier sind die video daten
also hier stehen quasi meine meine meine verschlüsselte nicht verschlüsselte
meine encoded video daten drin da hier in diesem packet wie kriege ich denn die
information dass dort in diesem speicherbereich das hier ist ja nicht
wirklich hier stehen ja nicht wirklich die daten drin sondern hier ist ja quasi
bloß die speicher adresse drin gespeichert wo der speicherbereich
anfängt wo die video daten drinne stehen so und wie kriege ich denn diese
informationen jetzt in diese funktion hier unten um dort raus den thumbnail zu
extrahieren wie sollte ich das großartig ohne pointer
machen und noch viel noch viel interessanter ist ich speichere mir
sogar die letzten für die letzten zehn sekunden video stream speichere ich mir
alle packets so wie sollte ich das machen ohne pointer geht ja gar nicht
ich muss ja die daten irgendwo hinschreiben und hinschreiben bedeutet
irgendwo in speicher und ich muss mir natürlich merken wo im speicher die
sachen sind weil ich kann ja schlecht jedes mal 16 gigabyte speicher durchsuchen
wo meine daten anfangen
man davon abgesehen ich weiß ja gar nicht wie meine daten aussehen dass ich
sie in 16 gigabyte arbeitsspeicher wiederfinden würde
und hier steht einfach nur der zeiger drinne hier in diesem an dieser adresse
man muss ja auch sagen pointer beschreiben nicht wirklich das ist das
ding die dinger nennen sich zwar das ist ein in pointer das ist ein ein av
packet pointer aber genau genommen sind sie das alle gar nicht
eigentlich sind das alles einfach nur zeige auf eine start speicher adresse
und was da drinne steht das kann prinzipiell alles sein
das muss ich aber wissen weil ich muss ja wissen wann ich aufhören muss zu
lesen also sprich wenn ich nicht wüsste dass
das in pointer ist ein av packet pointer oder sonst was in der richtung oder noch
interessanter wird ja bei irgendwelchen arrays
den array in c ist im prinzip oder generell in array ist eigentlich nichts
anderes wie der die information wo geht das array los und aus welchem typ
besteht das array wenn du diese zwei informationen hast weißt du in welchem
abstand deine elemente im speicher liegen gibt noch theoretisch andere
varianten aber das musst du wissen du brauchst den typ dass du weißt wie lang
ist ein element und du musst wissen was losgeht aber wenn du die zwei
informationen hast kannst du kannst du die sache lesen wenn du das nicht hast
ist halt schwierig so an der stelle ist es halt so ich brauche an der stelle wo
ich das packet anlege beziehungsweise den speicher den speicher reserviere für
das packet mache ich damit gar nichts so wirklich was machen tue ich erst hier
unten und dementsprechend übergebe ich hier den zeige auf den speicherbereich
wo das packet zu finden ist an diese funktion und die extra hier den
thumbnail draus anderweitig könnte ich das überhaupt nicht machen
wie wie sollte ich das sonst wie sollte ich die daten sonst von da nach da
bekommen die einzige variante die es sonst noch gäbe
wäre bei jedem funktionsaufruf quasi den kompletten speicher den ich
brauche immer zu kopieren was natürlich performance mese nicht so
sinn und zweck der sache den ansatz gibt es ja auch dass man quasi alle
argumenten quasi immer kopiert anstatt den pointer zu übergeben aber unter der
haube ist so ziemlich alles was irgendwie nach variable aussieht in
pointer ich weiß nicht ob dir das jetzt großartig geholfen hat aber das
eigentlich ist ich wollte sagen es pointe sind was abstraktes aber eigentlich
stimmt das gar nicht pointer sind eigentlich so das grundlegendste was es
im in einem programmablauf neben so basis kontroll strukturen ja was es
gibt
wenn du dir jetzt mal vorstellst du hast so eine ganz billige schleife so in
assembler oder so
du musst ja du musst ja irgendwo der cpu sagen wo was ist ja also selbst wenn du
oder wenn du den if hast in assembler so nach dem motto gucke gucke ob das
gleiche ist wenn nicht dann springe dahin ja wohin soll er denn springen an eine
speicher adresse an was sonst ich küsse deine auf macht lieber wieder tommy
gesagt hat geht die pointer küssen oder küssen oder küssen dann dein informatik buch
oder noch besser ich muss jetzt auf heul ist weihnachten
küsst weder pointer küsst noch euer informatik buch sondern küsst vielleicht
leute dies wollen und ist immerhin weihnachten und noch eine sache ich
kenne es noch ewig ich kenne es noch ewig ewig weiter mal nur point aber eine
sache es egal ob ihr jetzt gläubig seid oder nicht
ihr wisst dass ich persönlich jetzt mit religiösen sachen nicht so haben was
egal ob ihr gläubig seid oder nicht erstens erfreut euch dass ihr da sein
könnt ja das ist auch nicht selbstverständlich ich habe letztens ein
video geguckt da ging es drum
wie unwahrscheinlich es ist dass auf irgendeinem planet im universum überhaupt
kleinste lebensformen entstehen und dass sie sowas von unwahrscheinlich dass ich
eigentlich jeder glücklich schätzen sollte dass er nicht nur eine simple
lebensform ist die da so irgendwie in irgendeiner brühe rum schwimmt so so so
ein zeller wobei man wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen muss wenn ich mir manche leute
anguck dass da nicht viel mehr als ein ein zeller zu holen sind sondern dass
ihr derjenige seite ihr seid freut euch dass ihr da seid freut euch dass es euch
ganz gut geht und dass es vor allem euren angehörigen auch gut geht hoffe ich mal
zumindest verbessern mal ein paar tage nicht die welt denkt nicht an die arbeit
weil ganz ehrlich keiner der auf sein leben irgendwie zurückblickt jetzt sagen
auch scheiß endlich mal mehr gearbeitet habe ich schon oft gesagt macht einfach
mal ein paar tage das was ihr gern macht und vor allem mit den leuten mit denen
ihr vielleicht so nicht so viel macht oder irgendwie keine zeit habe wegen
irgendwelchen gründen
und macht einfach das worauf wovon ihr denkt dass ihr selber gerne drauf
zurückblicken möchtet dass ihr es gemacht habt
big brain big brain wins so leute wir sehen uns macht's gut
bis dann zu